hello everyone my name is charlene my
name is therese and we're here to
present a muse a music capturing game
so you're going for a walk and you put
on both ar glasses and turn on your
phone and open up the emu's app
as you walk with your bose air glasses
you will hear a melody
to your right you turn towards the
melody to get a better hearing of it and
if you like it you double tap on your
glasses to capture the melody
if you feel the melody it's not
something that you like you can shake
your head and let it go and by the end
of the walk you will have to capture
a series of melody and compose your own
little soundtrack
that you experience during your walk
so here's a little video of
fancy
so
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
okay so now we can do the demo
uh so the demo is set up where
if you take 10 step and it's in a very
high sensitivity for the step counter
because we're doing this indoor
to trigger a sound
and it's ready for everyone to try it
out
we have a very simple ui to indicate
how many melodies you encounter how many
step you took and then how many maori
capture the whole experience is aimed to
be phones down heads up and just for you
to walk you don't really want to be
distracted first of all
it's really just too enhanced and to
kind of capture the moment as you walk
so let me turn get on the app
here you go
you should connect and then you can just
slip the phone around your pocket
so this is not head direction dependent
meaning
one direction or the other it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter so the audio is
spatialized we experiment with we
experiment a couple times with
specialized music in order for the user
to kind of distinguish uh between like
the new cell and the sound that they uh
capture but during our testing we do
find out it does make the walking
experience more uncomfortable because
they would like to face the direction
they're walking at and so i'll keep
turning their head around
so uh
specialization in the moving uh
when they're moving isn't as
reasonable for the user to do as a
request so we cut that out
yeah and one thing that the more and
more we worked on
this game we wanted to focus on is
kind of distinguish it from just playing
your normal music and have it more of a
like meditative and almost reflective
experience and really make sure that
you're picking the sounds that speak to
you so that way at the end when you have
this song it's kind of connected to a
memory or whatever specific feeling that
you're having at the time
one big caveat all the music that's in
the app is something that we compose and
we're not we're not composer so the
music itself isn't
uh it's like the one we pick up that's
open source online and the one that we
kind of like dropped our own like little
drum set run being so they're not
a wide set of it so it's not super
descriptive of everyone's experience at
that time so
don't don't hate on the music too much
good
oh god
so implementation evolution
uh so
through our user testing um the
how to experience is it working well
yeah great so feel free if you want to
try it later on come on try it
originally we had several implementation
in terms of
having
having specialized music where we
described having the new audio coming in
different direction
the previous iteration when i first
started the idea is that in order to
capture music we want you to actually
face the direction of the music
you kind of be looking at it with your
uh
with the frame because you're hearing in
the direction of the sound
but then as we use the test we realize
again having while moving forward and be
and dictate what the user's head
direction be is not a reasonable thing
to ask so we cut that part down
the user just had the option later on to
change how many steps they want to take
just a range between low amount of step
depending on the environment to a higher
amount of step for the music to be
generated so if going for a long walk
they don't want to be bombarded with a
bunch of new music coming up they sell
like the longer generation
if they are indoor for example if you
just want to take a short walk around
office and snowing outside
then you do a short
iteration short generation
yeah so one of our main research
questions during this process was
how we can create
a
mind space using only audio
to make the player
more meditative and reflective
so
at first so we drew like a lot of
inspiration from a lot of different
places so i think obviously first is
pokemon go so originally we were
thinking um have a phone ar component
and you walk around and in addition to
hearing the the sounds also have like a
little sprite character where you would
point your phone there and then capture
on the phone
but we found that that really drew a
person out of their own head and put
them in more of a virtual world which
was kind of the opposite of what we
wanted
yeah so then another thing that we
started thinking about was meditation
and how when people meditate a very
common way to do that is to count to
your breathing
so one way that we wanted to implement
that
with audio is have a consistent cadence
so you kind of match your steps to it
and it's that like rhythmic meditative
state
and we found that it really helped out
the users to get into that mindset
and then during some play testing we
found in the beginning people were
really stressed out and it's a lot of
things going on new sounds a lot of
decisions that they have to make
and people were saying that was really
intense but the more that they played it
it became almost second nature and
players were really able to get into
that mindset as soon as they put on the
glasses and wanted to make these
decisions and make their own creation
so
the user that we've been asking around
having people who are really into
confusing music and people who are more
interesting and like just having music
in their life in general and one thing
that as we work with the instructor it
was the differentiation between
confusing music and almost like the
experience of bird watching where you
have spur the moment encounter and you
can choose to capture it or let it go
and
we want to emphasize the feeling of you
can sing the music but you don't want to
very sprout the moment inside like keep
tweaking it and premeditating over the
experience and recomposing over and over
again
yeah so that leads into our next
question
which was about control so
how does
the level of control that you give the
user affect the user experience so
as you were saying we had a lot of
different musical backgrounds of play
testers
so that can be frustrating for people
don't know a lot about
music or
it was just kind of
changing the experience in a way that we
didn't want it um so also if you uh give
the user the option as
of like as soon as you get a sound you
can change all these different things
about it
it made walks much longer and drew
people out of the experience because you
don't want to wait until the end to be
like oh that thing that i caught like 10
minutes ago like what can i do with it
so
it was kind of derailing the experience
and
presenting it more as kind of bird
watching experience really helped
align everyone's expectations so that
everyone would enjoy it and kind of
dealing with what you get and making the
most about of what you get
also supported our
our goal of having it as like a
meditative experience and kind of
analogous to life you just
make the most of what you get and
have something beautiful in the end so
it was really exciting
so the future iteration of what i want
to do is more
right now the current set of music is at
a particular vpn but sometimes on a slow
day you want a slower melody or you
found faster you want like a higher
pumping one
we would like to have an option for the
user to kind of choose that in the
beginning
ideally it's a input that's more
intuitive so it's i have the input so
it's hard to if i tell you
for someone who's not musically inclined
if i tell you oh putting into the vpn of
your choice they're not going to be able
to kind of have an idea of a 140 bpm
versus like 120 vpn how that feels
instead we want to be able to
incorporate more sensors such as the
gyroscope or accelerometer to kind of
like track their head knot to the beat
that they want so if they want a faster
b1 they could like shake their head a
little bit faster also b1 it'd be a
malware hashtag and from the tracking of
the b you kind of pre-select what music
you want to be able to offer to the user
so in the future we want to be able to
kind of
passively track users uh
physical
emotional state with the physiological
sensor that's embedded onto the ar frame
and this way have a more
continuous experience yeah
yeah and then right now it's all it's a
very personalized experience and one
thing that we wanted to implement in the
future is start to build a community
around that so right now
at the end of your walk you have this
song and you can just save it for
yourself but in the future we'd like to
have it
kind of as an open platform for a
community of other
users on the app and then maybe someone
has this really nice beat and then
someone else could
they could collaborate and add vocals or
like and make songs or just share with
your friends
so the whole idea started out with the
feeling that music can capture emotion
or like a certain moment
and we want to be able to kind of
incorporate that into everyone's life
and that's the goal of in views
hopefully
[Applause]
you